[Music]
thousands will take
it brother
how's it going it's going good good man
appreciate you meeting with me man no
worries man huge fan
thank you man thank you so much i'm
excited about the podcast we're about to
do yeah it's gonna be a lot of fun
so tell me about yourself i mean i know
this i know the michigan part i know
your your game like i know that
yeah born uh born and raised in toronto
uh when i was 15 years old i kind of
like got to a point where
um like i was killing high school
basketball in canada yeah
but at that point um you know canada
wasn't like really known for its
basketball so
uh i kind of took matters in my own
hands and like decided i wanted to move
to the us by myself
uh just started going to prep school
there to like to get noticed by like
college coaches whatever
so when i was 15 i left home like left
my parents and just kind of
they were okay with that uh my mom like
definitely
struggled she was like didn't want me to
go because like i like i wasn't ready to
go but i just knew i was like i want to
play in the mba like i know this is what
i need to do
um i ended up working out like i got a
lot of scholarships and then going to
michigan and then i did two years there
got drafted and now
uh it's my fourth year in the league now
i'm playing playing for the nets now so
um
man it's been a crazy journey so far and
like it's all it's all gone so fast like
it feels like just yesterday i left home
and i started going to prep school in
the us and now i'm 24 and
in my fourth year like a vet crazy like
right i just i
like that's the thing i feel like i just
got drafted and now i'm like
about to get my second contract and all
this different kind of stuff like it's
crazy how fast time flies so it's cool
man
how'd you first get into my st how long
have you known about my content
uh maybe about like a year and a half or
so
i had um when i was in philly my
roommate at the time
was like really into all your stuff and
oftentimes like whenever he was in
something he would just send it my way
like he would always like forward me
kind of like your instagram stuff or
whatever
and so like he sent me like a couple of
like pretty dope quotes that you had and
i was like i gotta check this guy out
and then ever since then i've just been
like
all your youtube videos and stuff like
that i've just kind of been on those
ones but
ever since i was a kid like i've always
been huge on like
mindset just on like yeah like
motivational quotes and like
inspirational stuff like all that kind
of stuff like
like ever since i was 10 like i always
like read those like michael jordan
quotes of like
i missed 9000 exactly you know those
ones yeah so
um yeah just like it's cool for me to be
able to actually sit down and talk with
you because like this is something that
like really interests me
um and just like the mind like i my uh
on my instagram like my thing under my
i don't know whatever you call it under
your name it says when you master your
mind you master your life like i've
always
i've always believed that something
interests me but like it's so much
easier said than done
100 because you have so many variables
that you weren't in control of
dna who your parents were where you grew
up
yeah but then you get to a point where
you have more control than you think too
many people think that it's over but
it's actually about
who you surround yourself with and what
you consume
that's true like like the end and we we
take it
you know it's funny like people realize
that if you listen to a bunch of hip-hop
music and this then the other thing
you know and live the culture you can
have swag but people don't realize that
you can do the same thing around
being a winner yeah just surround
yourself with winners
and just get optimistic instead of
pessimistic like it's it's it seems so
simple
you know it is it's actually no
different than what you did like you
took a lot of [ __ ] shots man like
when you were 12 years old you shot a
lot of basketballs
and like that mattered yeah like yeah
you were gifted with
the ability but the amount of people
that were gifted with the ability
is actually scary high it's the next
part that matters
and so to me it's reps yeah like to me
like being an entrepreneur like my
mindset was reps it's just always where
i was and by 42 i'm like just in it now
you know
and then the world changes you never
know i mean i was 34 years old before i
ever made
a piece of content for the internet like
i never you know what i mean like it
just never was like
how i saw it playing out yeah um and now
like
it got even crazier because
entrepreneurs got popular yeah
you know like having athletes and
rappers hit me up is just the funniest
[ __ ]
it's funny to you amazingly funny i love
it i love it right like
you know like growing up i grew up in
jersey so and then that's where in
jersey when i was growing up like
going growing up and going to a nets
game and having like chris morris like
wave at me would have been like
you know like you know and so like it's
the same old game and like
that's the cool part we live in such an
open world like sure
like that we can have like it's great
like one follow one dm it's cool
it's an amazing time to be alive yeah
you know what's crazy actually about
how um like when i dm'd you it was
actually
a bet like from one of my friends what
my friend he's like a big fan of yours
and your name just came up in
conversation one day and like we were
sitting on the couch watching tv and he
was like dude just go
dm him and like i bet you a hundred
bucks he's gonna respond
and i'm like dude garyvee's not res like
he probably gets a thousand of these
every day like there's no way he's gonna
read this
and so we like made the bet and we're
like let's set a deadline on like what
he's gonna reply by
so he was like three days he's gonna
reply in three days so like three days
goes by
and uh like you didn't i like look it
didn't even say like open
scene or anything so i'm like bro
there's no way like he
has way too many of these messages
coming out he's not gonna see it and
he's like
bro just give it a little faith like
he's gonna reply at some point i gave up
on them like two weeks later you hit me
up and you're like yo thanks for the
message
like really appreciate your support and
then you hook me up with tyler right
away
i was like dude it's crazy like one dm
like i just like took a shot out of
nowhere and
it's so cr it's real it's what i want
everybody to do like you can get to
people
yeah you know like you can get to people
not everybody some like i like people
and want to meet people and like
that's my personality and guess what
there's other athletes and actresses and
models and skateboarders and
rappers that are like that too yeah the
end yeah
it's not about a status you know yeah
it's about uh it's about a mindset
for sure back to that point you know so
how do you think about
your career and like life and like how
you know what's crazy about athletes is
i've gotten to know them is
you guys are so young when you're done
yeah it's crazy so like that's kind of
one of the things like when i came in
here like a couple questions that i had
like maybe that i should get like you're
going so like
i've listened to videos for you where
you were like were you just like i love
eating dirt i love
like i love like being on like the grind
and like
whatever and like that's cool like i
love the grind too like for me honestly
one of the best parts of my job is not
even like necessarily playing the games
during the season
but like when the off season comes
around and i have like a five to six
month period where i can just like
evaluate what do i need to work on and i
just like i'm in the gym
all day every day just like working on
what i need to work on how narrow or
deep
how wide or deep do you go on what you
work on in an off season
do you pick a singular thing and go
crazy i mean because you're playing at
the highest level yeah so it's kind of
like
you may just want to work on this one
left-handed thing
well that's the thing like i guess
there's a lot of different areas i work
on it's like this in the summer like i
kind of break it up into
three different like areas so like i
start my day like on the court where
i'll do like an hour after two hours on
the court and like in two hours you can
hit a lot of different
like working out a lot of different
skills like moves finishes
shots whatever dribbling what not and
then i really started getting pilates
this summer
flexibility flexibility like core
strength all that kind of stuff and then
there's weight training like you know
whether that's upper body whether that's
like gaining explosiveness like
so there's a lot of different areas that
i kind of divided up into but those are
three areas i'm hitting every day
but what like when you kind of said this
is like we're so
like when we're so young when we finish
one of the questions i had for you is
like
i love the grind and whatever but like
how do you like how do you learn to be
patient when like
our careers are so short you know what i
mean because it's like
well so let's talk about that so yeah so
like i think about the grind for
entrepreneurs
where the career is not short yeah
so are you asking about being patient
within a basketball framework
yeah so like or you asking it in a life
and totalitarian standpoint right
i guess more just the fact that like so
or do you think it was like i have
leverage while i'm a player what do i do
with it
i think my question is more like how do
i get the mindset of like
so like over my four years in the nba
like i've grinded and grind grinded
i've been like eating dirt and although
it hasn't been all bad like there's been
some
success here and there it hasn't been
the type of success that i wanted to be
so but at the same time for me like
over four years i look at it and i'm
like the average career in the league is
only four years like people don't
understand that most
guys only last four years and that's it
so most guys
yeah i mean that's the average that's
the average a lot a lot of guys
are like one or two years and they're
done so like for me i've made it to the
average
so far but like i have dreams of playing
10 15
years as long as i can play but even
with that i'm like
if i last 15 years i'm already 25 done
like i don't have that much time
yeah i don't like i don't think my
patience game
works out in something like sports yeah
i think it's different
yeah like i would i would be first of
all my whole thing is macro patience
and micro speed so macro patients i
still even an athlete's standpoint
probably can buy into my patients but i
would make it life not basketball
but like my if i wanted to be a great
basketball player
and i was four years into my career and
it hadn't happened yet
i would probably spend every single
minute on my game yeah
like i mean everyone like you might want
to leave right now
brother i'm being i'm taking the door
i'm being really frank with you like if
you're asked
actually asking me yeah i i would
probably study film
and work out yeah every single moment
of the next 24 months of your life like
no sitting on the couch with your buddy
dming me yeah zero that's like that's
zero
by the way zero i did it yeah from 21 to
30
my life was zero like straight up zero
like you have to understand yeah
i lived in jersey and never came to new
york city to go out on friday saturday
sunday
and when i say ever never zero times
that's crazy so like that's what's real
though like people don't understand
greatness is about obsession yeah like
like otherwise wouldn't everybody be
[ __ ] great yeah like so if you're
you're four and you're like [ __ ] man i
really don't want to regret this and
like i'd like to have like i'd like to
the course of my career to change i
follow the sport enough to know yeah
then dude you actually have to go 100
yeah like no friends no girls
basketball that's the truth yeah it's
the truth
that's the truth that's the pa that's
that's actually eating dirt when i talk
about eating dirt
people are like oh yeah i eat dirt i
work hard
that's working hard eat dirt yeah
that's what it is man so i know that's i
know what's kind of cool is like you're
in a sweets in my opinion in a sweet
spot to try it my big thing for you
right now is kind of like [ __ ] try it
do it do it for 18 months just see what
happens so what's really crazy about
your game though it [ __ ] me up
is you could like like like you could do
it
like everything could be perfect and you
can get hurt yeah that just [ __ ] with
me so much
and you see it in the nba this year like
even chris that's presents the other day
just go to tornado like 12 months he's
gonna be out
and it's like it's just like the harsh
reality of the game but it's a harsh
game but look i mean like anything in
life
being a professional athlete in america
is about it it gets
that's pretty up there bro oh i i love i
mean of course
i mean it was my dream since i was a kid
so i can't complain but like
i guess another question i have is like
how how do how do you think i should
how should i go about evaluating what i
need to change in terms of my routine
because like
like to be honest because to be honest
like
it's to the point like dirt i've ate
dirt to the point where like they'll
like they've banned me from coming back
to the gym at night like i just came
here from practice and like oftentimes
i'll go back home like i'll take a nap
or whatever it is and then i'll go back
at night
and it's gone to the point where they're
like dude you can't keep coming back
like it's not good for your body like
you need
like at a certain point for athletes you
do need rest so i
here's what i would do i would go look
at as many people as possible
that have mapped a similar career to you
and actually accelerated their career in
year five or six
like literally like have somebody one of
your college buddies
you like somebody that like a fan like
figure the [ __ ] out who the 29 guys who
had the most similar path to you in the
last 10 years
and actually talk to every one of them
dm them yeah call like during the
fraternity
definitely definitely do that and i
definitely think you need a
uh i think you should really consider
hiring somebody
okay you know yeah like i don't know
sport well enough to know like who those
basketball coaches are and how they
roll and like what that is but that's
potentially what it is you know yeah
i guess like that's it's like one of the
most frustrating parts for me is because
like when i've been on this journey
especially over the four years like
i haven't seen the success that i've
wanted to see but everyone keeps like
every coach that i've been coaching i've
played for three different teams every
coach
and every like teammate i have like
everyone's like you're gonna be okay
like you're on the right path like
trust me like your hard work's gonna pay
off but like after four years
of it like there's certain parts of your
mind we're like are these people just
like telling me what i want to hear
here's what's up it doesn't matter yeah
like what's the alternative yeah it's
true there's no alternative
right like that's see how simple that is
actually it doesn't matter
if you're like getting gassed up give
the ten minutes with phillips before we
do that
toronto okay um
it doesn't matter if dudes are gassing
you up yeah what's the alternative
i'm not quitting so so that's it that's
it's binary
yeah you just i mean there's one middle
ground which is you mail it in right
yeah and then the league will tell you
that it's time to quit yeah so you're
quitting anyway right
exactly so i just think things are about
the alternative man like people ask me
[ __ ] all the time like
i just get real basic real fast i'm like
and
like right like my answer to everything
is and
nobody can be mad at people that are
kind to you and just
wanting to like you know like being
outside like they tricked you like you
know the score like you're the big thing
for
athletes is sometimes you need that
moment that break
that that moment right that
those two guys get hurt in the same game
and drop 17 in seven minutes and
that's just real life that's sports yeah
that that's the reality like unless like
there's obviously a lot of superstars
in every sport but it's crazy especially
in basketball a lot of the guys like get
their first opportunities off of like
players getting hurt like players in
front of them get hurt
and they just step into a role like if
you don't realize like draymond green
on the warriors like that's kind of what
happened to him like david lee
david lee got hurt that's exactly what
happened he steps in awesome draymond
green becomes draymond green
but like most people realize that yeah
it's crazy it happens
all the time man yeah that's exactly
right
that's exactly right and that's it like
all you can do is like people always ask
me when are you gonna buy the jets i'm
like
like what if what if the woody johnson
doesn't want to sell it to you i'm like
i can't control that part yeah
it just becomes a laser focus on
focusing on what you can control
yeah you can't control the guy in front
of you getting traded or
hurt or falling in love and falling off
like there's a million
there's a million things in life all you
can do is do the exact same [ __ ] that
got you here
you know for sure
i would i would really really really
like
consider like reaching out to a couple
dudes that lived your life
yeah and they're out there yeah i've had
i've had the pleasure actually like so
this year when i started in philly
um i started the year in philly and uh j
we signed j.j reddick
and do you know who jj read very well so
and jj was the guy that was like
similar like very similar to me like his
first like five years maybe in the
league like
i mean yeah he was okay he was like
decent but like
not what he became not not what he would
not what he is now and not
how he was performing at duke like in
college like it was just like a drop off
and like it took him like five years and
what was he saying and like for me he
was like dude trust me
like i've been in this league now for 10
years like i can tell like you're going
to be fine like he's another guy that's
honestly honestly you're going to be
on the right path honestly that's a big
one because you know i
i also know enough to know that like i
don't he's from what i know about him
and i know a lot of people know him
pretty well like
he's not in the business of saying that
to you yeah he's a nice dude yeah i
don't think he would say
like but he doesn't know and like so it
goes both ways that's my whole thing
with like love and hate
like both are guessing yeah
it's true you just you can't and you
can't even like
some of the best players of all time
just sat the bench for the last eight
years and never happened
yeah it just might that could be real
yeah but what you need to do is make
sure
that if you get the right things the
right coach the right team the right
moment or the right opportunity that
you're in that spot
because that's the part that will bother
you like if you got caught up in the
vortex of the machine and just the wrong
teams at the wrong times or the right
people ahead of you
you'll always be like okay like you know
as you get older you're like [ __ ] man
i did get to play in the league which is
bonkers but yeah [ __ ] right
but if you get the shot and you get to
play the last 19 games in the year and
you play like [ __ ] because you don't go
there
that one will hurt yeah that's the thing
like in my like especially when i got
i've gotten traded here to brooklyn um
and it's been tough like we have a lot
of guards on our team but like the
opportunities that i have gotten
like i've played well i know a lot of
those games
here's the good news the league's
watching oh i know the league's watching
but then it's like it's tough because
like guys come back from injury and i
kind of like i step back to that
so like it's more of like a patience
yeah but you know the way i look at that
straight up is like look there's two
things that happen there things i can't
control guys came back coach decided
and things i could control i could have
you know and i don't know
in enough detail but i know you played
well like
i don't know you know what's funny i
just take blame for everything in a good
way yeah
like i hear that and i i if i was had
the luxury to play i'd be like
well i could have dropped 35 and a
quarter that's the same attitude i think
that's good
all my that's like all my friends like
oh you played so well today i'm like
well clearly i didn't do enough
because i wouldn't dwell though i know i
mean i try not to dwell on it but like
just like
you control what you control and you
know yeah
and by the way like sports is tricky
like in a in a microcosm anybody can
play well or not well
yeah for sure you just got to keep like
you got to keep
the hardest part is keeping your mental
game up mm-hmm that's it
yeah and it's the same thing for you or
like all the kids that are [ __ ]
in debt right now right like what's the
tough part being in debt
still working not getting a raise
getting past happening might
we could walk the floor right now same
thing they're thinking about like why
didn't i get that raised why didn't i
get promoted at vayner i got this debt
like [ __ ] it i'll go to this other
like it's the game for everybody yeah
just different circumstances
i'm